Un petit clap.
DTC saison 2 c'est tipart
*musique du générique*
Je pense que toutes les séquences commencent par c'est parti.
quand tu veux.
Tu me fais un petit clap.
C'est parti quand tu veux.
Quoi un un un.
Fait un clap *d'une voix bizarre*
On la double.
Quand tu veux.
Là vraiment on est sur un tic verbal.
Hey salut Romain !
pff
Ça commence tellement bien.
Ok.
aller
C'est parti.
ACTION
un gros rot
C'est parti.
*rire
Alors ?
C'est quoi déjà?
Je le dis quand tu te touches les seins,
un moment.
J'ai oublié de te dire.
pff
Ah.
Ma misse !
Ah ben oui julien ah ben dit donc.
Donc euh ...
C'était nul putain.
C'est partiiien.
Un petit clip hein.
Okkkk
Manger doucement.
Cet effet vise à ...
Fake
Il me regarde.
Je regardais l'image.
J'ai bavé comme un porc.
Bah écoutez, cette prostate me semble parfaitement normale.
Oh mon dieu !
Aller.
Vas-y.
C'est bon ?
Oooooh
Ooh hey oh.
Ta gueeule
C'est marrant hein.
C'est parti. On est sérieux. hop.
On en trouve aussi dans le cul de Romain.
Bien au fond à droite.
Olalaa
Oui Julien. C'est ça.
Pourquoi c'est à la mal au ..
C'est incroyable.
Sinon  une personne pense que je suis vraiment con
J'espère tout le monde.
Parce que je me donne du mal.
Humour !
Alors ...
Oh putain, j'me suis tué.
Bêtisier pour abonnés VIP.
C'est finit pour aujourd'hui.
Vous allez tous crevés, alors faites pas chier.
Dis camion
J'ai un peu honte de ces blagues.
Ça tourne toujours?
oui oui
ok.